I've heard people say listen he's
out-of-the-box thinker he's a
businessman he's an entrepreneur but
people that know this man I wouldn't say
you would say I'm normally a business
plan you're not a businessman no no what
are you I'm gonna show there's probably
lots of analyst on Wall Street who agree
that I'm not a businessman okay well
what do you think you are I'm engineer
like engineering in design but you're
not a businessman well I mean I don't
sort of like look at things from like
what's the rank ordered list of
priorities or based on a return on
investment just a Mac that I don't
really do any investments I've been on
the own wine in public security and
that's Tesla that's it I've no diversity
in terms of public securities I've heard
you describe yourself as a technologist
yes exactly
technologists make new technologies
create new technologies is it your is it
your dream to conquer the world and make
the world a better place to what is your
dream technologies like magic you know
to put I mean I don't like technologies
the closest thing to magic that we have
in the real world and so I think like
engineering creative engineering is
essentially technology development and I
just move us when I said I like Lord of
the Rings is my favorite book is it yeah
that's really like what's the closest
thing to being a wizard in the real
world and that's like creating new
technologies